[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster well today's
program is all about two battles the
rail unions over paying conditions and
the SMP over a second Independence
referendum how far are they both
prepared to go to get what they want
well Scotland's first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon says that she respects the
Supreme Court decision to rule out an
independence referendum without
permission from Westminster but of
course that won't be the end of the
matter and she's not the only one
picking a fight with a prime minister
12 long years of Tory government five
Prime Ministers seven chancellors why
did they always clobber working people
if the labor party is serious about
actually supporting growth maybe they
should get on the phone with their union
pay masters and tell them
when we talk about the unions later in
the program but there's certainly plenty
for us to get stuck into as we bring you
takes from all sides over the next 60
minutes and of course we'd better to ask
than the most important people you at
home we are going to be seeing what our
viewers panel made of it all and all the
politics at the minute there they are
hello everyone give us a little wave out
looking forward to seeing you later on
the program as well we'll also have some
top guests for you including the
transport secretary Mark Harper we'll be
talking to the S P's Westminster leader
in Blackford who'll be in the studio for
us and we'll be talking to Labor's
Olivia Blake who asked the pmq of the
week in our view and much more besides
of course on the take
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I just want to pause the politics for
just a moment and talk about football
because today Japan beat Germany 2-1 now
in club terms that's a bit like my team
Jeffrey Wednesday winning at anfield the
staff of dreams but if the World Cup is
shocking Us in all kinds of ways there
were no surprises at the supreme court
this morning the judge's decision to
rule out a referendum on Scottish
independence without the consent of
Westminster was exactly what had been
predicted well let's kick off shall we
with some of the biggest moments of the
week so far
the Supreme Court will rule this hour on
whether the Scottish Parliament has the
power to call for a second Independence
referendum the Scottish Parliament does
not have the power to legislate for a
referendum on Scottish independence in
my resolve to achieve independence is as
strong as it has ever been indeed it is
if anything today even stronger I think
that the people of Scotland want us to
be working on fixing the major
challenges that we collectively face the
Prime Minister has every right to oppose
Independence he has no right to deny
democracy to the people of Scotland the
rmt union has announced a series of
48-hour strikes on the railways in
December and January we have been
reasonable but it is impossible to find
a negotiated settlement when the Dead
Hand of the government is presiding over
and blocking a resolution in these talks
England and Wales as captains will not
wear one love armbands at their World
Cup matches in Catalan later we have had
a number of instances the former Wales
Captain Laura McAllister who was going
into her team's game against the United
States last night wearing a rainbow
bucket hat and it was taken offer
now you might have spotted the rmt union
leader Nick Lynch in that Montage
someone whose face has become very
familiar to us over the last few months
now tomorrow he is going to be meeting
the transport secretary Mark Harper to
talk about the pay dispute which
threatens to cause Christmas Chaos on
the railways first though Mr Harper came
into the studio I began our interview by
asking him about reports that
restrictions on taking liquid on flights
could be lifted
I'm very keen to talk to you about rail
strikes of course but I just want to
start with a story that the times is
reporting which is saying that the
limits on taking liquids into airports
onto airplanes are going to be stopped
by 2024 is that correct well I
understand that store is off the back of
some commentary from one of the bosses
of an airport and I'm afraid you'll know
our usual practice on security matters
is we don't comment on security Maps I
think it's quite important I'm now
responsible for setting the security
regime for our Aviation sector so you
know if there are any changes coming
we'll set those out for people in due
course
um but at the moment the the regime is
as it is with the strict limits on the
limit liquids people can take on planes
I mean the times are saying that because
of advancements in Scanners the limits
are going to be unnecessary I mean that
would be quite welcome to use for
travelers wouldn't it well look I'm sure
I'm sure people would like to not have
those limits but they're in place for a
very good reason if that should change
in the future then I'll obviously we'll
set that out but you know the security
regime is in place for a reason it's
important that people follow it
um you know we always keep these matters
under review but at the moment the
position is as it is okay now you're
meeting with the rmt tomorrow the rail
Union what's your message going to be
well look the reason for meeting very
clearly I'm not negotiating with them
that's very clearly for the trade unions
and the employers Network Rail and the
train operating companies but I do think
in this in this case it's important to
meet with the unions um this isn't just
these these strikes are not just about
pay this is about long-running talks
that are actually about delivering rail
reform people will know that because of
the pandemic significant number of
people have stopped using Railways you
know the number of passengers is around
80 percent of what it was pre-pandemic
that set up some very significant
financial challenges for the industry I
want a thriving viable financially
sustainable Railway that's the only way
you actually secure the jobs of the
rmt's members so it's the same shared
agenda and I want to set that out to Mr
Lynch and the other Trade union leaders
about that being our ambition and I
would urge him and the other trade
unions to get around the table I'd urge
them to call off the strikes get back
around the table with the employers try
and Hammer out some of those reform
homes that are necessary in which
deliver the savings that can then help
pay for pay Rises for his members and
deliver a better service you know these
strikes are going to be damaging for
passengers they're going to be
redisruptive for the first Christmas
we've had that hasn't been impacted by
covid a big hit for the hospitality
sector how much will it cost the economy
you think well look it it's going to be
a very significant cost it's going to be
no I haven't but we've already heard
some very significant cost estimates
from the hospital from UK Hospitality
you know that's a sector that was hit
during covid you know I spoke up for
that sector when I was on the back
benches you know the Prime Minister when
he was Chancellor tried to protect that
sector and these rail strikes are going
to be very damaging can be damaging for
the people in the rail industry who are
going to lose their pay and their their
overtime but they're going to also hit
people in the hospitality sector they're
going to be damaging for passengers and
I would still urge the unions to call
off the strikes get back around the
table and try to hammer out an agreement
and that's what I'm going to be saying
to Mr Ninja meet him tomorrow I mean you
know you're saying there that you're not
involved in the talks that they're
between the rmt and the train operating
con companies I guess some of our
viewers will be thinking hang on you're
the transport secretary why don't you
get involved surely this is exactly the
minute for you to actually try and make
a difference you know just look at the
dates of the strikes the 13th 14th 16th
17th of December the third fourth sixth
seventh of January just when people as
you say hospitality industry people can
be trying to find the fam going to see
their families they're going to be
wanting to get into the Christmas spirit
why don't you get involved well look
they are very damaging and and I am
involved in the sense I'm going to set
out very clearly what our ambition is
why it's important that the unions reach
a deal with the employers but the detail
matters here so it's about the specific
reforms that Network rail need to see in
their maintenance operations it's about
the specific reformers we need to see in
having a seven-day Railway more flexible
Railway and it's about pay as well what
do you think of inflation 11 is it fair
for transport workers to be expecting to
see their pay matching inflation well
look the difficult challenge that we've
seen big challenge for the economy uh
because of covid so that was a you know
one in 300 year hit to the economy and
we're recovering from that we've seen a
uh at the made in Russia challenge you
know because of their illegal infections
do you think that the pay for transport
workers should match so so the reason
why I'm putting in context is because I
think the context matters
um the most important thing for
everybody in the country whether you're
a transport worker or or some other
public sector worker or someone in the
private sector is that we get inflation
under control that's why the chancellor
set out a credible economic package last
week
so that's the concept what's the answer
well and so that means that although I
completely understand why people facing
these cost of living pressures want more
pay the government is simply not in a
position to pay inflation pay rise is
and if we were to do so the danger is
that we would embed inflation and that
wouldn't actually be in anyone's
long-term interest what's in people's
interests is that we get inflation
driven out of the system so that it
comes back down to a lower level we see
interest rates then falling that's how
we get a long-term sustainable position
I accept it's difficult for people and a
Chancellor made that clear last week
none of this is easy but there is a
context here and I think that's
important for for the rail unions to
understand as well as other people who
who obviously are pressing for higher
pay Rises now MIT Lynch of course takes
a different position on this and many
other things as well to be fair now I
just want to have a look at what he said
earlier
he said the Secretary of State the
rather than sitting on his hands he's
got to get down to the serious business
of creating a settlement yesterday I was
told by the most senior person working
for the training operation companies
that he's been stopped from offered
offering us a deal he's being prevented
from doing that by the Department of
Transport and it seems they're stuck on
the idea of continuing this dispute into
the new year is that right that the DFT
in the department for transport and
yourself as a secretary of state are
blocking the train operating companies
for offering no look at the end of that
quote there we're Mick Lynch was talking
about us wanting this to go into new we
absolutely do not I I don't want any
strikes to take place
I want the dispute to be settled look
I'm not going to get into
um you know throwing accusations around
I want to have a sensible conversation
with him tomorrow where I set out the
context of what we're trying to achieve
which is recognizing the railway
industry has had a big hit because of
the pandemic the imperative is to get
reform so that we get more people using
the railway we drive up Revenue we drive
out cost we deliver the ability for the
train operating companies and network
rail to be able to offer better salaries
and wages to people that work in the
industry and that can only be achieved
by the trade unions in the employees
getting around the table and hammering
out those reforms and I want to I want
to try and help facilitate that and
that's the message that I'm going to be
delivering to him tomorrow now in other
news the Supreme Court ruled today that
the Scottish government can't call an
independence referendum on its own
unilaterally Westminster has to agree to
it as well
so if the democratically elected
Scottish government requests permission
to call an independence referendum would
you grant it well look the government
made it very clear today the Prime
Minister has asked this question it will
varying Soviet prime minister's
discretion State and he made it very
clear look the priority for I think the
people of Scotland and indeed everyone
in the UK is to focus on the issues
facing the country which is deal with
the economic challenge protect people
from energy price Rises
um and the consequences of the war in
Ukraine and that requires the UK
government and the Scottish government
working together and I think the really
um a positive thing that the Prime
Minister did he was the first Prime
Minister for many years to go to the
British Irish Council he sat down with
um the Scottish first minister they had
a very sensible conversation about about
priorities and I think that partnership
working is what we need to see and
that's that's the priority for the UK
government you talk about the priorities
of the Scottish people but Scotland has
voted for the Scottish national party
that they argue is their mandate I mean
the clues in the name of the Scottish
national party they're not standing on a
platform to do anything other than
deliver Independence well I think if you
look at actually what the Scottish
people want they want the government
actually to be focused on both
governments to be focused on the
day-to-day challenges they've voted in
the Scottish national party who is in
their manifestation to use their powers
and you know the Scottish Parliament has
a tremendous set of powers to deal with
the things that it is responsible for
which is you know running the Health
Service in Scotland running the
education system in Scotland delivering
better Services is there a line at which
you would say okay this is when a
referendum should be allowed what is
that red line is it for example you know
the SMP getting a majority in the
Scottish Department well look our
position is very clear we think the
position at the moment is that the UK
government the Scottish government
should be working together focused on
the priorities that are facing the
United Kingdom is there a route to a
referendum that you can spell out what
look we we had a a referendum in 2014
and the the position that was agreed and
that was settled not not just between uh
Westminster and the Scottish government
but actually agreed across Civic
Scotland was that that was a once in a
generation referendum and we've
respected the result of that referendum
and that referendum was that Scotland
stayed in the United Kingdom and that
means Scotland has two governments it
has a Scottish government and it has the
UK government and those governments
should work together I understand the
results of the referendum but the
question is is there a route to another
referendum well the priority at the
moment is for the two governments to
work together on the issues facing the
United Kingdom
and those are the issues that I set out
which are the economic challenges
protecting people from energy price
Rises and dealing with the economic
challenges and then delivering on the
public services that we deliver you know
the UK government's responsible for
delivering those in England the Scottish
government's responsible for delivering
those in Scotland and the Prime Minister
will work with the first minister in
Partnership to deliver on those
priorities for for the people in both
parts of the United Kingdom okay thank
you very much indeed for being on the
program pleasure
oh my interview there with Mark Harper
well we can get some reaction to that
now and speak to the S P's Westminster
leader in Blackford I mean I was quite
struck by Mark Harper not really being
able to spell out a route to a
referendum what did you make of the
interview well that's quite
extraordinary review because we were
told that this is a partnership of
equals it's a union of equals and of
course if you have such a union you need
to have consent
Mark Harper talks about the Prime
Minister working with the Scottish
government look we want to work when
it's right with the UK government we
work together on Ukraine for example we
all Stand Together
but
there has to be a respect for democracy
and but you know Mark Harper talks about
2014 of what happened what he admitted
to see was that after that referendum
all parties came together under the
Smith commission there was an agreement
about more prayers for the Scottish
Parliament crucially every party signed
up in that document to another
referendum if the people of Scotland
chose to have one what happened in 2021
is that we had an election to the
Scottish Parliament now we have two
votes there's the constituency msps and
there's less for us look at the way that
Westminster does that look at the
constituency msps we won the vast
majority of the seats to that Parliament
63 out of 73 there is a Independence
majority in that Parliament you know
when the government is in power it's
imperative enact its Manifesto and
there's a manifest of commitment from
ourselves and our partners in the greens
of delivering an independence referendum
in the second half of the Scottish
Parliament it is not a good look for
Westminster to say we don't hear you
we're going to ignore you you can't
continue you to ignore democracy we know
that the route for the Scottish
Parliament calling its own referendum is
not one that's viable after the court
action today and we respect the decision
of the of the Supreme Court but again
that's Westminster that has legislated
through the Scotland act to stop the
Scottish Parliament going down such a
route there has to be a way in that
scenario that the Scottish Parliament
the Scottish government can trigger a
referendum and of course in the previous
referendum we had the Edinburgh
agreement that was an agreement of the
two governments that that referendum
could take place Westminster can't just
hope this goes away it won't do away so
what is your next step then you say you
respect the Supreme Court decision my
message to the prime minister is is
recognize the reality of that mandate
that the Scottish Parliament the
Scottish government has we should have
talks that allows the Scottish
government to have a section 30
Authority that we can have that
referendum now I if we don't have that I
would regret that position but that then
means what the first Minister said that
the the next election that we're going
to face as a Westminster one the only
option that we would have the only
realistic option option for now would be
to use that general election as a de
facto campaign for a Scottish reference
is there a problem though because what
you're doing there is you're saying that
people are voting in an election as if
it's a referendum but of course the
people vote in elections for all kinds
of different things we look at the
living standards issue that people are
now facing look at the NHS look at
schools look at Energy prices people can
vote for all kinds of different reasons
you can't just say they're definitely
just voting well on a binary issue we're
of course going to have a conference in
the early part of next year and we'll
debate all these things and we'll come
to a very firm conclusion about how
we're going to face this but we're in a
situation that Westminster is not
recognizing
the harsh reality of our government in
Edinburgh that has that mandate so if we
have to look at mechanisms such as using
an election and then we would have to
appeal to the people of Scotland to
recognize that this is a one-off this is
about making sure that Westminster does
listen to the voices of the people of
Scotland and of course we're setting a
high bar because we have to win that
election and win it with more than 50
percent of the the vote actually it's
interesting if you look at the 2021
Scottish election and the less votes
slightly more than 50 percent of the
voters voted for independent supporting
parties so we will take that challenge
if we have to but of course when we have
that debate it's about what kind of
country it's about how you respond to
that cost of living crisis it's about
how you deliver sustainable economic
growth you say um that it would be a
one-off I mean that's what we were told
last time wasn't it with the last uh
Independence referendum one of the
points if you look at the two the two
agreements the Edinburgh agreement and
the Smith commission at the end of it
there was nothing in either of these
documents that said that this was a a
once in a lifetime opportunity but oh
that's all sort of member
you know you you go through the
documents I know you're across all the
detail but for many people they'll think
look you've already had a different
Independence referendum why'd you want
another one two things have happened
Sophia since then one is that we were
told in 2014 if we stayed in the UK that
we'd be staying in the European Union
and that's real makes it harder in some
ways doesn't it for an independent
Scotland you'd be talking about a hard
border potentially we passed foot
control with Customs checks we know that
people in the EU said that you're going
to have to adopt the Euro if you want to
become a member we can go through these
things one at a time but the point is
that if you look at Pauling and Scotland
72 percent of people in Scotland want to
be back in the European Union
Independence creates an opportunity for
us to do that the opportunities that we
have for trade and investment as a
consequence of coming back in the
European Union it's about making sure
that we can deliver the economy that we
know that the people in Scotland look we
have seen a decline in population on a
relative basis with the United Kingdom
for every decade for the last 150 years
we have to change the record I know
through green energy for example simple
we can upscale our production five-fold
we can deliver 385 000 jobs in energy as
a consequence of doing this we have a
plan for delivering growth for
delivering prosperity of delivering on
our climate climate targets and we need
the powers of Independence to do that
why for example Westminster is holding
us back in carbon capture and stories
there are many examples about the things
that we would do that would transform
the Scottish economy now you talk about
trade and so on take Ireland as an
example you go back to the post-war
period more than 80 percent of Ireland's
trade was with the UK it's now nine
percent because they've grown the
overseas markets and actually over that
period And every year iron's trade with
the UK has grown there is a growth
opportunity that we will deliver on
delivering Prosperity driving down on
the poverty that we're inherenting from
the current regime it's a message of
Hope and we will do this we will win
this argument I think tonight there's a
lot of people in Scotland have a resolve
that we will not be silent and not be
stopped by the UK government not
recognizing democracy is it the truth of
it that you know in some ways it quite
suits the s p to be talking about
independence because it means you're not
talking about your record in Scotland
and what's currently happening in
Scotland I mean let's look at the NHS
for example the worst any waiting times
figures on records 6 000 vacancies in
nursing and Midwifery uh minutes of the
meeting of course of Scotland's NHS
leaders in September saying there's a
billion pound hole in the budget so it's
not possible to continue to run the
range of programs the NHS currently
offers while remaining safe and doing no
harm this is really frightening stuff
it's an absolute priority of the health
secretary and the government to improve
the outcomes in NHS Scotland we know the
responsibility that we've got to do that
is not good enough then yes I admit that
that has to be better look I could say
to you if you can trust the performance
of NHS Scotland against other parts of
the United Kingdom then we outperform
other parts of the United Kingdom
however we have to do better I
absolutely accept that but one of the
problems of all of this Sophie you look
at what happened last week with the
Autumn statement the fun something that
we get is largely driven by the
consequence of the UK budget and our
budget in real terms has been cut this
year that's the reality we don't have
the borrowing parts we know that we need
to drive investment into our Public
Services look at what's going to happen
in the UK over the next four years five
years 30 billion pounds of cuts to the
public space it's not just about money
though is it look at these minutes
minutes again everything is a top
priority what is the real Focus it's a
managing issue as well isn't it you know
I can talk about my own health board at
NHS Iowa then I've got some great people
there that are leading that organization
but we've come through the covert crisis
there's a backlog that we have to
contend with and we should applaud those
that are working really hard in our NHS
the other thing of course is that they
are discussing the possibility of a
two-tier Health System let's just rule
that out completely that will not happen
whether wealthy will pay for treatment
that will certainly not happen in
Scotland whether that's in the current
status or in an independent Scotland NHS
care will be free at the point of use
for everyone
I'm interested to know your thoughts on
the new UK prime minister Rishi sunak
can you do business with him easier than
Liz Trust
you know we've had a really difficult
period with Boris Johnson endless trust
we had no relationship no relationship
with the devault administration but
that's as opposition parties I'm looking
forward to having a a normal
relationship where we can work together
and for example I've been asking him for
more support for the tider industry for
example so we can wrap that up of course
I will want to do things whether it's in
order interest to do so work together
over Ukraine stand up against Putin but
it has to recognize democracy
uh now just finally uh World Cup fever
unfortunately of course Scotland didn't
qualify who are you going to be
supporting in the World Cup I'm looking
forward to seeing all the games and I
wish I think importantly I wish Wales in
England all the best and the people here
can celebrate the competition and really
enjoy seeing their teams playing and I
just aggrieve the fact that my country
on this occasion and sadly once again
not there uh talk about celebrating did
you celebrate a little bit when Iran
pick one past England no I didn't
adopted of course not
I wouldn't dream of doing such a thing
thank you very much for being on the
program good to see you thank you
uh rights uh well let's just show you
shall we uh just some pictures from uh
Dundee because rallies have taken place
this evening in cities across Scotland
calling for a referendum on Independence
you can see at some of the images uh
there but we can take a moment now shall
we and talk to our chief political
correspondent uh John Craig who is our
analysis Supremo uh this evening on the
take um you've been listening to the two
interviews we've had so far Mark Harper
in Blackford what stood out to you well
just go since it's the most recent
interview I was interested when uh Ian
Blackford said just now that they had no
relationship with Boris Johnson do you
remember at Prime Minister's questions
when Time After Time Boris Johnson said
to Ian Blackford actually he and I get
on very well we're on very good terms so
uh we can't both be right can they
um the arguments that Ian Blackford was
uh talking about about the uh the uh
elections the Scottish Parliament last
year we heard that in the Commons
chamber today because first of all Mr
Blackford tackled Rishi sunak at pmqs
then he had an urgent question to
Aleister Jack and they kept not just to
Ian Blackford but all the SNP MPS and a
lot of them spoke today kept on saying
we've got a mandate from those elections
in last year more than 50 we heard it
from Ian Blackford just just now voted
for independent parties or candidates
now that was hotly disputed by Aleister
Jack today who kept time and time again
saying that's not right it was only a
third voted for pro-independence parties
so I think we can expect to hear a lot
more of that now as for Mark Harper
interesting that he's having a meeting
but it's a bit like um last week it was
Steve Barkley talking to the nurses
leaders wasn't it too that they are
Royal College of Nursing what is the
point of a meeting if you're not
actually going to talk numbers now I
think that I'm writing saying the latest
offer to the rmt I think is eight
percent over two years
um and I remember Grant shapes Mr
Harper's predecessor kept saying come on
put that to the members and they haven't
um so that was a complaint that Grant
shaps used to make I think I'm writing
saying Mr Sharps I don't think had any
meetings with with Mick Lynch
um uh Mick Grinch as he's been called
today uh he said I'm not the Grinch I'm
a trade Union official but uh they I
mean potentially for everybody this
Christmas those dates you read them out
earlier on there's also an overtime ban
uh from the December the 18th to the 2nd
of January it's a whole of the Christmas
period but I predict I'm not sure that
the meeting between Mr Lynch and Mr
Harper is going to really achieve that
much tomorrow doesn't feel that way
particularly of course with Mark Harper
saying that you know they shouldn't
expect to see uh inflation at matching
pay Rises uh John really good to have
you I think one of your first times in
the take I think you have been with us
before
the cold in Downing Street one night
yeah you're back in the warm today a bit
rainy tonight so good to have you John
you're watching uh the take busy show
for us today we're live in Westminster
up next we are going to hear our pmq of
the week where we give chance for a bat
venture to respond to what the Prime
Minister had to say
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
welcome back live to Westminster you're
watching the take now to the political
highlight of the week prime minister's
questions and the theme of today's
exchanges between kirstama and Rishi
sunak was
which side are you on
he won't follow Labor's plan to make oil
and gas giants pay their fair share in
sturdy hammers working people
and he won't push through planning
reform instead he kills off the dream of
home ownership
too weak to take on his party too weak
to take on vested interest 12 long years
of Tory government five Prime Ministers
seven chancellors why do they always
clobber working people
[Applause]
Mr Speaker he talks about leadership
this summer I stood on my principles and
told the country what they needed to
here even though it was difficult when
he ran for leader he told his party what
they wanted to hear
and even now even now he says one thing
and he does the other he says he cares
for working people but he won't stand up
to the unions
he said he he said he'd on a brexit but
he tried to have a second referendum and
now he tries to talk tough about
immigration but he promised to defend
free movement
you can trust him you can trust him to
deliver for his party you can trust me
to deliver for the country
[Applause]
the comments this afternoon it does feel
doesn't it like train strikes are a big
dividing line at the minute in
Westminster uh so I think it'll be
interesting to see what people watching
on Sky News Made of it all I'm actually
interested to get the take of our views
panel this evening on the strikes to
have sympathy with workers do they
actually uh think that the government
needs to do more to try and stand up to
the unions let's find out shall we can
go to Roy first Roya conservative voter
talking to us from Kent this evening uh
Roy here's your sympathy with when it
comes to train strikes
um the passenger basically I think this
is more about politics than pay at the
moment uh Mick Lynch has a has an ax to
grind Spanish practices need to be taken
care of yes they need to be paid more
there is a problem about baking in
inflation I think that is a that is a
real issue
um and we take a short term as few as
always for the last six years we've been
taking a short-termness view of of of
um
of policy I'm not thinking about the
long term
um and I think it started with the rail
unions it will move to other public
sector pay and um we're going to bake in
inflation it's I'm just sort of
hunkering down for another six or eight
years of pain basically economically
speaking interesting I mean that did
really kind of echo with what Mark
Harper was saying about how you can't
embed inflation into pay expectations
let's go to Rod's next hour to see what
your take is on this Roz McMillan labor
voter from York whose side are you on
when it comes to the real dispute
well I'm on the side of working people
and the working people in this instance
um are the members of the rmt some of
whom are extremely poorly paid
and I mean when you listen to Mick Lynch
and then you listen to the Tory
government it's quite obvious who who
you trust who's telling the truth when I
heard Rishi sunak today at Prime
Minister's questions the cures accuse
kirstana of being on the side of the
unions and not on the side of working
people I thought he needs a history
lesson he needs a civics lesson who the
heck does he think the unions are and
it's as if they're trying the government
are trying to pretend that we are 50
years ago uh it's it's totally bizarre
the rich are getting richer the poorer
getting poorer we've had 12 years of
Tory government
five Prime Ministers seven chancellors
and it's a mess it is a mess they have
destroyed the economy and they are
making life extremely difficult for
working people and I think we are in for
a very very difficult time but what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to turn workers against workers and
frankly that is not going to work I
don't think the British public are going
to be fooled by that one job right well
that's two very contrasting views there
on the strikes that's bringing Kevin
shall we Kevin burden he's talking to us
at from Cardiff if you describe yourself
as a voter from the left
um do you think that rail workers should
get an inflation uh mashing pay rise
well I think it's inevitable that all
workers will want to try and keep up
with inflation it's running away I I'm
um like we sold a house
um a year ago and and had the money in
the bank we're desperate desperate to
buy a new house because the value of the
money was uh eeking away so you know
whether you're a worker you're a
pensioner or you rely on savings it's a
terrible time to be
um trying to make ends meet I mean I I
what happened a year ago is that we
moved from England to Wales and um you
know one of the first things we noticed
was how much better public transport is
here the trains are better there are
more buses there are more services
they're more frequent they're more
reliable and um it does seem to suggest
that there's something different about
the way it's organized I don't think
public ownership is a Panacea the the
the the the
um the public transport is largely run
through the Welsh government here
um I don't think it's a Panacea I
remember British Rail
um but it does suggest that a different
model and a different approach does have
some success and it's less likely
perhaps to lead to conflict interesting
stuff there about the actual standards
you know on our Railways mattering as
well as the kind of pay dispute uh too
right let's bring in Belinda shall we
now Belinda you're talking to us from
Twickenham in Southwest uh London you're
a swing voter aren't you so which way do
you swing when it comes to the rail
strikes
well I went to Inverness um on Sunday
night and came back on Monday night and
if any of the other trains hadn't worked
it would have ruined my whole trip I've
booked another ticket in December and so
just never knowing whether anything's
going to go ahead or not it's really
upsetting I'm worrying for people when
things go wrong for workers for students
when strikes keep going on so long
nobody's meeting in the middle so the
the government and the and the trade
unions nobody's meeting in the middle of
people are either being stubborn or
they're just not coming up with a
solution of any kind whatsoever so I
think you know damaging passengers lives
workers lives you know there comes a
point where maybe you should only be
able to strike so many times there's got
to be maybe a cap on how many times you
can actually strike yeah certainly
important isn't it talking about you
know the impact is having on people a
particular course in the right after
Christmas as well um is our battery
charger let's go to you next you're
talking to us from London
um what's your position when it comes to
the rail strikes do you have sympathy
with the rmt
yeah I actually do have sympathy with
the rmt I think the the rails rights are
obviously going to be disruptive for me
but that's kind of the whole point and
if you look at most rmt members they've
not had a real terms pay increase for
years they're not your kind of
relatively comfortable tube drivers
those are represented by a different
Union and so actually looking at a a pay
rise which is still less than the
inflation rate feels not crazy
unreasonable for me and the the
disruption I think is something that I'm
kind of willing to stomach given the the
cost of living crisis and the kind of
reasonable ask for a pay increase right
let's talk to John then shall we finally
uh John Comerford a conservative voter
you're talking to us from Ashbury in
Kent John do you have sympathy with the
rmt or are you concerned about the
disruption the stripes might cause
I'm very disturbed about the passenger
and the disruption that they're going to
suffer
um the timing
I know they've had these strikes on for
a long time but I think the time of this
latest lot will bring probably the worst
disruption as far as people are
concerned and I'm just disappointed that
the government who I you know I do
support I'd like to see Mark Harper get
there tomorrow and bang a few heads
together as opposed to uh you know just
just saying he's going to facilitate
something he's a very good MP he's
certainly done well over the years let's
see him come to the the table tomorrow
and try and get a result before these
strikes start there you go I can see a
couple of her panel members nodding
along with that part of your answer
Johns though I think there's a bit of
agreement there in hoping for a last
minute resolution thank you so much all
of you for giving your views on the rail
strike something I'm sure at many people
at home are going to have concerns about
as well thank you
now it's our regular chance to speak to
our adventure as we pick our pmq of the
week it's the one that really caught our
eye during the session earlier today
it's this one today
uh struggling with sound
uh we're gonna try and sort that out
okay
struck on the sound what in that case
what we can do instead is go directly to
the person who asked the question and
hopefully they can actually fill us in
on what was said a few technical issues
this night but you know otherwise as
smooth as anything we're joined Now by
Labor's Olivia Blake now unfortunately
we should actually hear you uh because
of sound issue on the screen but just
talk us through what was it that you
asked the Prime Minister um so today oh
thank you for having me on as well
Sophie and just to say the question that
I asked the Prime Minister was um about
the fact that tomorrow marks one year
since 32 people lost their lives in the
channel
um and the families have not had any
closure on this because the
investigation that is being done
um in on the UK side into this hasn't
concluded yet so my questions were
three-fold really when why is it taking
so long for the investigation to come to
its conclusions if there will be a
public inquiry following that initial
initial investigation and finally
whether the Prime Minister felt that the
lack of safe routes and passage to the
UK for people to claim Asylum had led to
people taking boats into this country
and what did you make of the prime
minister's answer to you I think that
his answer was very vague and I was
quite concerned because
um he basically didn't want to answer
any of the questions that I kind of put
to him directly he said that that this
is a country where people can claim
sanctuary and Asylum which is absolutely
true but the problem is how people get
here and today we saw Sue Ella bravaman
struggling to answer that very question
of if you were a minor
um you know under 18 trying to get this
country trying to flee war and conflict
how would you do that and and they
couldn't answer that question because
Missy this is partly isn't it because
they're a safe and legal routes from
certain countries of Hong Kong Ukraine
Afghanistan but otherwise you're
supposed to claim Asylum first thing we
want to get to the first into the United
Kingdom but they also say don't they
that you need to claim it in the first
safe country you pass through well that
isn't actually the case so so well
Braverman again at the um Home Secretary
and home Affairs committee today said
that people are completely within their
rights to claim Asylum here and the fact
is is it's so difficult to get here and
like I say if you're a child we've taken
away those safe routes of getting people
to the country from various countries
um across the UK and we know that 98 of
people who get in those small boats go
on to make an asylum claim we've seen
how Ukraine we can do things differently
we can stop people taking those perilous
Journeys by offering them the
opportunity to come through a legal and
safe route and I think that's been a
success story really and how we can
manage this in the future to give people
that opportunity
um to apply for Asylum and and we have
to admit that the rates of people being
granted Asylum is increasing and
increasing year on year partly because
of the massive disruption across the
globe at the moment that we're seeing in
several countries and that are not in
those bespoke deals that we kind of have
with how we support people
um to claim Asylum here there's some say
right the Labor's position on
immigration is a bit vague it's a bit
confusing but they're not sure if
kirstama thinks that look we need more
immigration because it's the right thing
to do to help people from other
countries but also to fill shortages in
the labor market or if Kirsten was
saying look actually you know
immigration levels are too high people
have legitimate concerns about it what
is Labor's position so I think you know
I'm here to talk about Asylum and
refugees I think that that is the driver
of the boat situation I think that safe
and legal routes and and the PCS Union
and care for Calais last week I was
chairing a cross-party discussion around
a paper that they've just put out with
some really simple and ideas about how
they could make the system fairer how
they can make the system less likely to
result in deaths but also make sure that
people who want to claim and have a
reason to claim are able to do so and
those that don't will be put off by not
being being having the decision made
before they get here and I guess if you
ask the government about the situation I
remember having Robert generic sat in
the same chair as you a few weeks ago he
would say that actually there is a
significant proportion of people
crossing the channel who are economic
migrants including from other EU
countries well like I've already said 98
of the people who come on those votes
will put in a claim for Asylum actually
this 71 rate of acceptance of Asylum
claims on the first go that's up up on a
few years ago and you know we often hear
about albanians now as a woman I have to
say it would be very nice to me to sit
here and say that Albania is a safe
place for Albanian women 86 percent of
the Asylum cases granted to women who
have probably been victims of
trafficking that should be of concern to
many many people and that is again a
staggering amount of people who are
getting
um their claims accepted it's incredibly
difficult to have a fictitious claim in
this country you have to have real
grounds to be granted Asylum and I think
as as a woman to me it's quite insulting
to see those people being portrayed as
economic migrants when they may be going
into things like prostitution
thank you very much for being on the
program I need a glass of water so we
are going to go to a break thank you for
coming on and talking about your
promises question thank you lots more uh
coming up on the take we are live in
Westminster next up we'll be rounding up
everything we've heard with some
post-match analysis from John Craig
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Alex Crawford and I'm Skye's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
foreign
a lot of action going on
a lot of
people
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in news
[Music]
look at her arms I can put my entire
hand round
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this Hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain World
[Music]
Mother Nature is can be vicious
absolutely Savage
[Music]
holes now down to a chapel in places
I can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge Lake OH
[Music]
closest
this is what makes the job
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
hello welcome back we are live in
Westminster for the take lots of takes
this evening whether it is on the unions
and the rail strikes of course set the
rmt meeting with Mark Harper uh tomorrow
but I have to say after our entry with
him I'm not exactly confident that
there's going to be a resolution
tomorrow shall we say and also of course
talking to Ian Blackford about that
critical ruling by the Supreme Court
that they cannot unilaterally call an
independence referendum in Scotland
without the agreement from Westminster
well to take stock of it all we're
joined by our chief political
correspondent uh John uh Craig John it's
lovely to have you on the program uh
this evening uh so much going on in
Westminster are there any stories that
are particularly standing out to you at
the minute to keep an eye on well the
World Cup's underway and is uh Dominic
Raab about to get a yellow card or
possibly even a red card this afternoon
the Prime Minister announced that the
inquiry into those allegations against
him are going to be led by a q you see I
must admit I've not heard of before Adam
Tolley sorry Casey isn't it Casey Adam
Tolley KC who actually once acted for
Charles uh in 2005 in an unfair
dismissal and sex harassment case uh it
was brought by a member of Staff the
complaint was not about the Prince
Charles as he then was so this guy Adam
Tolley is really is a a Casey a proper
KC because he's acted for Charles he's
also acted for hmrc against uh some TV
celebrities over there uh tax Affairs so
you and I won't get caught on any of
that of course
um according to the announcement he's
going to establish the facts about a
complaint made last week about Mr Rob's
conduct at the ministry of justice and
also the facts about his conduct at the
foreign and Commonwealth office so
potentially quite uh serious for Mr Rob
and as you might exactly imagine the
opposition parties upon child in tonight
Angela Rayner for labor has said there
must be no hint of a whitewash when it
comes to the slew of serious allegations
Mr Rob faces and the lib Dems Wendy
Chamberlain says if he's if the case is
upheld he should be sacked remember the
pretty Patel case of course uh we
believe it was upheld and yet nothing
happened so
um
ceramic Ferguson would say squeaky bum
time wouldn't he for uh for uh Mr Rob he
would uh it's interesting isn't it John
because it feels like you know people
like you and I have been in Westminster
for some years now
um these stories about bad behavior
about about bullying about power
imbalances they come round at me every
few years and we we stand here and we
talk about them it should be said of
course that uh Dominic rob you know that
invitation ongoing he denies the claims
but more generally the culture in
Westminster
do you think there is an issue about how
junior members of staff are treated well
let's let's separate ministers in
Whitehall and MPS in Parliament
ministers in Whitehall as we've heard
it's a it's an independent inquiry the
cabinet office is involved and uh it's
it's all in Whitehall for MPS there's
this new body newish it's set up during
the pestminster Scandal a few years back
it's the independent complaints and
grievances scheme and it's really to
help youngish members of Staff who feel
bullied or face sexual harassment from
older mostly members of parliament now
I've spoken to lots of House of common
staff who will tell you it's Toothless
and it's useless and they always find in
favor of the MP or nearly always anyway
and so there's a lot of dissatisfaction
and we hear complaints don't we against
various members of parliament all the
time and there there is a mood certainly
in certainly a man's house of common
staff that the the whole system is
rigged in favor of MPS so it's not ideal
really the system the other thing I'd
say as well is you know with these
things with these stories that do appear
I guess you know every now and then and
almost cyclically you I'll talk to the
MPS or the ministers on the Wednesday or
night program like this or on the Sunday
Morning Show and they'll all condemn it
they'll say it's terrible they say it
shouldn't happen but then you ask them
what should change in Westminster should
they close the bars should they change
the HR processes so MP is no longer uh
you know employ their staff directly and
no one can really come up with any
actual change I'm not sure closing the
bars is the answer I mean okay I can you
know you think back over the years there
was the Eric Joyce incident in the
strangers bar I remember doing that I
think we reported nothing together Eric
Joyce was MP for full Kirk and he he got
you know he started lashing out at
people and there's been various
incidents in other parts of the Palace
of Westminster as well well there's a
bar called the wool sack which used to
be called the sports and social club now
they tried to clean that up because
there were various incidents there why
you shouldn't close the bars should you
just because there's a bit of bother you
wouldn't close a pub just because you
know there's a bit of an incident a bit
of a ruckus
absolutely you know it's been a real
pleasure having no one closing the bars
there you go final word from uh John
Craig it's been uh great having you uh
on watching uh the take this evening and
thanks very much for being with us a
really busy show for us and of course
we'll be keeping a close eye on that
meeting between Mark Harper and the rail
unions lots more coming up on Sky News
after this short break see you next week
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]